[Música]
bom eu vou falar com vocês sobre o que
aconteceu na muito tempo atrás
na realidade o começo disso tudo foi o
casamento do meu pai ea minha mãe em
pederneiras onde ele morava e onde os
pais tinham um pequeno hotel que
garantia sua sobrevivência
meu pai casou com minha mãe em 1930 uma
época difícil porque 28 houve a grande
quebra da bolsa de nova york
isso afetou a economia do mundo inteiro
e também da pequena cidade de
pederneiras que perdeu os seus usuais
hóspedes do hotel que eram viajantes
detido comércio é que estava tentando
vender daquela maneira de ti é quase que
de porta em porta de cidade em cidade
oferecendo os produtos com essa
diminuição das rendas
o que aconteceu meu pai como ele era
muito empreendedor ele não se conformou
de ficarem são lá em pederneiras
esperando que a coisa melhorasse
então ele foi para são paulo indo para
são paulo a coisa não era muito melhor
tinha outras oportunidades então ele
viveu em são paulo até 1940 onde quando
ele recebeu uma oferta para trabalhar
numa imprensa no rio de janeiro
isso foi de fato uma mudança muito
grande de vida e planos saímos de são
paulo para morar em copacabana onde meu
pai alugou um pequeno apartamento ali no
fim da praia quase no posto 5 e meio
quase chegando lá no forte de copacabana
essa mudança foi a meu ver uma transição
muito importante pra mim por e fui
estudar um bom colégio em copacabana que
chamava se colégio abc souza a onde tive
excelentes professores se lembro
e em rio de janeiro dessa época era a
capital do país
então quase tudo de bom digo melhor da
cultura brasileira como energia para só
para rio de janeiro
então aí aí fiz o curso fundamental e
quando terminei o curso fundamental foi
fazer o que antigamente se chamava
colegial e tinha que fazer uma opção fiz
uma opção pelo curso curso clássico
porque eu tinha muito amor pelas letras
pelas artes e pela música e não tinha
muita é digamos assim compatibilidade
com essas atas
mas quando cheguei lá nesse colégio
mesmo no curso clássico tinha um pouco
de química física biologia e eu me
encantei pela química a por causa de um
professor strone dário professor alberto
um belga radicado no rio de janeiro
ele era médico profissional então
resolvi fazer vestibular para química
para a chamada faculdade nacional de
filosofia da universidade do brasil que
era similar à faculdade de filosofia da
usp dessas faculdades de filosofia se
concentravam todas as ciências básicas
então você tinha no andar química no
outro física no outro biologia no outro
matemática e assim por diante
então com isso até filosofia então tinha
aí nessa que de seguida difícil que
tinha sido o consulado da itália mas que
foi confiscado pelo governo cerca de
1937 por causa da guerra
os súditos do bié tudo todos os súditos
do eixo gastos tiveram seus bens
confiscados e isso aconteceu lá no rio
de janeiro e eu então estudei desse
prédio que fica muito próximo do da
cinelândia que da cada da candelária do
teatro municipal de todos o querido
galera realmente o centro de grandes
atividades culturais do rio de janeiro
então foi uma sorte foi uma mudança de
paradigma eu digo que eu mudei a minha
visão de mundo quando eu fui estudar
nessa faculdade nacional de filosofia
tive excelentes colegas lá encontrei meu
marido e ex marido que já estava na
minha frente então em 1953 já formados
nos casamos na realidade naquela
faculdade de filosofia desde o começo
encontramos um professor maravilhoso um
cientista de primeira linha chamava-se
professor costa ribeiro que fazia
pesquisa numa área que não estava em
moda digamos assim na ciência
naquele tempo dessa nesse nicho final da
década de 40 e conversou década de 50
era mais em moda a física nuclear a
física de partículas na física teórica
dessa mesma desse peso campos da física
o costa ribeiro fazia pesquisa sobre
propriedades elétricas de materiais
isolantes que é uma coisa de ciência dos
materiais e digamos assim usando uma
linguagem atual
então nós começamos a trabalhar e e
acredito que o costa ribeiro dos aceitou
avião sérgio por sermos químicos e como
ele trabalhava com materiais
o dois químicos poderiam ser muito úteis
também ali e realmente foram realizados
trabalhos interessantes que foram
comunicados da academia brasileira de
ciências
eu somos extremamente gratos ao costa
ribeiro e honramos muito sua memória
bom o que acontece tão terminado o
discurso estávamos casados nasceu o
primeiro filho nós tivemos que pensar na
sobrevivência econômica e tanto
queríamos fazer pesquisa como queríamos
fazer docência
mas para conseguir ter um salário que
permitisse mais uma vida de classe média
inferior digamos assim era obrigado a
trabalhar 10 obrigados a trabalhar em
vários lugares porque ninguém não existe
um sistema de tempo integral no rio de
janeiro mas já existe em são paulo
então o meu pai que era uma pessoa muito
comunicativa teve ocasião de vir a são
paulo e aí foi
por causa de uns projetos que ele siga
no rio na ante sala do reitor da
universidade de são paulo
ali encontra o professor teodureto souto
que ela estava é o professor da poli
técnica que estava encarregado de montar
de iniciar o funcionamento da escola de
engenharia de são carlos
meu pai muito falante perguntei vai tudo
bem ele disse vai tudo bem temos alunos
mas tem um grande problema
até agora não conseguimos um professor
de física
meu pai naturalmente falou o seu
problema está resolvido
meu gênio e minha filha é são
recém-formados trabalhem com costa
ribeiro e querem fazer pesquisa e então
ele eu conheço é o terrorismo disse
é para isso que nós teremos do emprego e
dos salários em tempo integral
nós não queremos apenas docentes nós
queremos pesquisadores
meu pai chegou a ex do rio nos contou
essa novidade e houve o contato entre
teoria de sérgio sérgio veio aqui
conheceu a cidade foi muito bem recebido
pela comunidade local e decidiu
realmente que essa era a única maneira
de fazer pesquisa no brasil
se tivesse pelo menos um salário tempo
integral e tempo disponível
nessa época quando nós decidimos vir a
surgir essa aliás eu voltei pergunta mas
é uma afirmativa dos nossos professores
e colegas lá do rio de janeiro
no seu caso as cargas a fazer um
suicídio intelectual porque vai se ver
pela capacidade de seguir do interior e
não vai ter chance de fazer nada estava
redondamente enganados porque nós
chegarmos aqui nós não nos isolamos o
resto da comunidade
continuamos com atividades como
convidando pessoas para vir e participar
de nossas atividades aqui em são carlos
conseguimos trazer até 1959 mais ou
menos mais quatro pessoas do rio de
janeiro e jovens recém formados que
vieram trabalhar no departamento de
física da escola de engenharia e já
estava fermentando bastante pesquisa
porque seguir a mesma linha de pesquisa
do costa ribeiro o sérgio fez uma tese
do livro não sei se mais uma tese de
professor catedrático
acho que ele foi um dos professores
catedráticos mais jovens da usp
então chegamos e 58 já com toda essa
carreira feita e então surgiu a idéia de
fazermos um estágio do exterior
encontramos é foi tomada a decisão de
irmos inclusive deixa eu voltar atrás um
pouquinho a situação era desesperadora é
aqui na esc porque havia um gp que no
gerador de raio x onde começamos a fazer
os nossos trabalhos e os serve com a
ajuda de excelentes técnicos que vieram
da escola industrial conseguiu construir
equipamentos e trouxe do rio doado pelo
costa ribeiro o equipamento e muito
simples mas que permitirá fazer medidas
que era um eletrônico vôo que permite
fazer medidas pequenas cargas que é
elétricas que é o que é consciente média
nos de elétricos
então houve com esse pequeno equipamento
e com espírito este pequena quantidade
de equipamento e com muita criatividade
construindo componentes e tal foi
possível fazer tudo isso que ele disse
então fomos pra pitico e eu fui
trabalhar na universidade de ti ti bpo e
sob orientação do professor jeffrey o
inglês e era um grupo extremamente com
uma grande variedade de participantes de
várias raças de várias citações do mundo
da ásia da américa dos estados unidos da
espanha é assim por diante então eu
comecei a me acostumar com o ambiente
cosmopolita da ciência que é isso que
realmente toca à ciência e sérgio foi
para o instituto de tecnologia onde ele
foi estudar defeitos em cristais
isso porque as propriedades dos cristais
dependem da estrutura atômica dos
cristais sua distribuição dos atos
dentro do crystal
elas essas propriedades são modificadas
adequadamente com introduzindo-se vários
tipos de defeitos na estrutura correta
isso muito importante por exemplo e
semicondutores
então ele fez um excelente formação
ficamos quase dois anos nos estados
unidos e retornando sá céu casos
pensando em continuar aquele tipo de
pesquisa e o mais interessante é que
nessa época numa via sociedades de
física nem de química nem de biologia
havia sbpc então participava nos
constantemente das reuniões da sbpc
sérgio inclusive chegou a participar da
diretoria da sociedade e tudo isso e
participando das reuniões da sociedade
nós participávamos do ambiente
científico existentes na época então
aqui tem uma fotografia quando foi
fundada sbf e julho de 1966 lado sbpc em
blumenau e essa reunião muito produtiva
organizada pelo sérgio inclusive com a
participação no centro a caixa a a acim
encolher quase sentado no chão o sérgio
porto que era um grande cientista de
estado sólido brasileiro que trabalhava
na bell leves
em 1968 foi realizado o 1º simpósio de
física do estado sólido no brasil
promovido pelo sérgio e com a presença
lhe dão extrema esquerda do professor
sérgio rezende que foi um dos
presidentes do cnpq e todos esses peças
pessoas foram os pioneiros da física do
estado sólido no brasil é que em 71 é eu
promoveu uma reunião com fico pessoas a
área várias áreas para fundar a
sociedade brasileira de cristalografia o
que manteve digamos assim um ambiente
muito bom para a cooperação entre os
cristãos novos e eu quero salientar que
a presença de dois líderes muito
importante pra nós que foi o grosso eo
bob zimmerman
o que estamos a colaborar de maneira
muito intensa e da física do estado
sólido e também no início de abril
física em seu carlos bohn e 72 já fui
para pitbull de novo e lá fiz medidas
usando de prata o metrô automático para
mano cristais todinho ele comandado pelo
computador computadores e usei mais
computadores de bairros poderosos e
cheguei à conclusão de que não vai do
tinga sentido trabalhar com métodos
antigos fotográficos onde as medidas são
teóricas longas têm leva um tempo enorme
só para colher dados 50 o computador vai
botando as duas medidas e botando tudo
lá na memória ea gente fica só esperando
que ele faça as medidas e do seu poder
fazer outra coisa e antigamente tinha
que fazer as medidas e impedir todos os
resultados dos experimentos nas chapas
fotográficas
então isso aqui foi uma quebra o
paradigma por assistir uma quebra de
paradigma da qualidade de trabalho que
se podia fazer no brasil foi um projeto
aprovado com muita dificuldade pela
fapesp em 74 chegou em 75 e 76
organizamos um curso internacional padre
para discutir as novas possibilidades
teóricas e experimentais que esse
equipamento pelo proporcionam e 72 é da
nossa família boston nava sérgio vai
poder saber de ortopedia onde ele
realizou um trabalho de biofísica de
couro sobre a estrutura no osso e eu fui
fazer uma primeira tentativa e que
estava grávida de protegidas até aquela
época eu só trabalhava conquistar na
grafia de pequenas moléculas
isso daí não foi assim no rendeu de
campo nenhum peito mas rendeu
experiência para mim
de bota aí eu poderei vai te dar como
poderia fazer isso em são carlos
naturalmente a coisa que mais era
necessária era ter um jovem que quisesse
fazer cristalografia de proteínas e aqui
a explicar a direita e estou recebendo
11 uma homenagem quando completará 80
anos
e o que me deu essa homenagem foi o
ganso livre que foi presidente do cnpq e
até r 120 e que muito jovem entrou no
nosso departamento e começou a se
mobilizar pra querer fazer
cristalografia de proteínas e embora sua
formação original fosse na ask com a
engenharia elétrica e ali ao lado eu
escolhi um desses oportunidades em que
eu recebi algum prêmio que foi quando o
jornal do brasil deixou de fazer a sua
edição impressa e tanto quanto eu saiba
passou a fazer só impressão digital e de
fato eles escolheram mulheres para serem
homenageados está ali uma atriz eu a uma
bióloga depois o atleta depois ubaí uma
pianista que fomos premiados pelo
cantando pela nossa carreira e em todas
essas áreas
eu achei e do fazer um bernard que
reunisse mulheres de todas as áreas e
deu apenas ciência porque a mulher não
precisa ser cientista deve ser excelente
do que essa faixa seja lá o que ela
quiser fazer né
tem até um ditado aqui a mulher faça
aquilo que ela quiser saber que aquilo
que ela quiser
finalmente depois que o garoto chegou
nós fizemos um congresso ritmo o
simpósio internacional de cristalografia
e que trouxemos grandes especialistas e
reunimos os poucos jovens que estavam
interessados em instalar a grafia de
proteínas
isso daí foi um banco coisa que ajudou
muito porque algum desses professores
ficaram do nosso grupo além daquela
semana ele lá no guarujá e dos deram
excelentes concelhos como obter mão
cristais eo vocês podem me perguntar por
que é fazer que só grafia eu diria que é
por todas essas razões aqui a
cristalografia da ciência
interdisciplinar com muita importância e
de 60 equipamentos muito caros
o velho se construir um novo sítio que
chamamos de sírios
quero agradecer a presença dos meus pais
sempre presente na minha vida
ali eles estão do dia do batizado do
paulinho eo filho caçula está aqui e uma
festa que nós fizemos em são carlos o
ano passado para os 90 anos do sérgio eu
quero agradecer a acolhida que tivemos
em são carlos para velloza com muitos
bons amigos daquela época que alguns
estão mais conosco mas que permitiu
vivendo numa cidade pequena conviver com
a minha família pessoal própria e com
muitos amigos que podem cair de será
imediato nos encontrar em todas as
ocasiões e que estamos festejando ou
estamos simplesmente fazendo um pequeno
churrasco ou qualquer coisa assim então
agradeço as oportunidades de vida feliz
e tivemos de são carlos rodeados de
amigos e rodeado da nossa família
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]